[MUSIC PLAYING]
Three, two, one, action,
you're supposed
to say, aren't you?
Action.
I'm Paul Wilkinson,
and I'm 68.
I was born with AKU, and I was
diagnosed at 16, and I was
referred to a London hospital.
I'll tell you how
I describe it.
AKU is a genetic metabolic
disease.
The body can't deal
with protein.
It turns the protein into
homogenic acid, and the acid
eats the cartilage away.
I understand it's linked
to chromosome 3.
Patients with alkaptonuria, or
AKU, have trouble breaking
down protein, and this leads
to the harmful buildup of a
compound called homogentisic
acid.
It is a recessive genetic
disease associated with a
defective gene on
chromosome 3.
So in order to get AKU, patients
must inherit two
copies of this faulty gene,
one from their mum and one
from their dad.
This makes it a very
rare disease
So they're born with
the condition.
So therefore, all you can see
initially is just dark urine.
By around the age of 25 to 30,
they start to get back pain.
They start to get discoloration
of the ears.
And progressively, over time,
the knees and the hips, all
the joints of the body
start to become
involved in this process.
I'm Professor Ranganath.
I'm a consultant at the Royal
Liverpool University Hospital.
And I'm the clinical director
of the National Alkaptonuria
Centre in Liverpool.
Funded by the Department
of Health, the National
Alkaptonuria Centre opened in
June 2012, and for the first
time brings together a team of
specialists to help treat and
monitor AKU patients.
So we quickly realised that
people with alkaptonuria have
problems walking.
Mobility is impaired
significantly in patients.
And that is a hugely important
issue for quality of life.
In my 30s, my back of my neck
was the first thing that began
to get very stiff,
very painful.
And then, within a very short
while after that, one of my
hips virtually went in a
matter of months, just
crumbled away.
The cartilage gets brittle,
and it breaks up, and over
time leads to pretty much the
damage of the whole joint.
And the ultimate treatment
that's all the rage is joint
replacement.
The National Alkaptonuria Centre
are now collaborating
with the Liverpool John Moores
University to analyse gait
impairments in AKU patients.
Because the joints undergo this
kind of degradation, the
inevitable effect of that is
that the way the person moves
will be affected.
So what we've been doing here
today is called "clinical gait
analysis." It's basically the
scientific method of measuring
how we walk.
I've been walking up and down
with these markers on my legs
so that, I think, they can
analyse my walking method,
what's good, what's bad.
We analyse it scientifically.
We can then pinpoint which
joints are damaged and what
mechanism might be affecting
mobility in these patients.
From his gait, we can see if
he's making any compensations.
Obviously pain is one of the
biggest predictor if you
change a gait.
So if something looks abnormal,
and in that area he
says he has pain, we can kind
of connect the dots.
We can give some advice to the
patient on how, perhaps, to
avoid some compensations and
prefer another type of
compensation that puts less
stress on their joints.
Paul was walking quite slowly.
That was the first obvious
thing that we noticed.
And having been through so many
operations, I'm sure that
he has had a fair share
of trouble and
difficulties walking.
I'm having some real mobility
issues in my left foot, and
I'm under a bit of pressure
to have some more surgery.
It's quite difficult
at the moment.
The National Alkaptonuria Centre
is currently trialling
a new treatment called
nitisinone that helps prevent
the buildup of homogentisic acid
and, therefore, eliminate
the harmful effects of
this rare disease.
Since 2006, 2007, which is
really quite short period of
time-- six or seven years--
we have made enormous strides,
and we're now on the brink of
a treatment for alkaptonuria.
Oh the black pee. i haven't
got the black pee now.
I feel bereft that I haven't
got black pee.
So I have known Paul for
nearly six years.
And he commenced the nitisinone
last year when he
came to the centre in October,
and he has been on that for
one year so far.
But he's doing really well.
A matter of weeks, if
not months, the
black pee had gone.
For the first time in 60-plus
years, I peed normal colored
male urine.
What was that like?
It's just amazing,
really, isn't it?
For more information about
alkaptonuria, visit the AKU
society website,
www.akusociety.org.
[MUSIC PLAYING]